aidé par des chiens c'est secouristes
travaillent sans relâche depuis des
heures dans les ruines de cet immeuble
nous cherchons des survivants des gens
qui sont présumés en vie mais aussi des
cadavres
dimanche les recherches se sont
poursuivies toute la journée sous l'oeil
des rescapés traumatisé
l'explosion a été très longue il nous a
semblé que c'était très long
mon enfant et moi on a crié si fort que
j'avais mal à la gorge 5 minutes après
l'explosion nous n'arrivions même plus à
bouger
l'immeuble de 75 appartements a été
touché de plein fouet par un missile
russe deux étages ont été détruits dans
l'explosion qui a aussi touché les
immeubles voisins
je n'ai pas entendu l'explosion et la
fenêtre m'est tombée dessus c'est tout
dans la ville près de 2000 habitants
sont désormais privés d'électricité et
de chauffage selon l'état-major
ukrainien Moscou a procédé à trois
frappes aériennes et à une cinquantaine
de tirs dans la journée de samedi